[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well these are certainly the cleaner
steps on Madison Avenue
that's how mr. day watch them kept
good morning
[Music]
we're new here aren't you
justice Marvin this is the way mr. daga
snap
[Music]
Annie be careful on this dish you could
burn your hands and keep the cover on
till you're ready to serve them
yesterday likes his muffins hot I'll do
that
[Music]
[Music]
Annie is the table set for breakfast yes
ma'am good morning ma'am
good morning Annie how are you getting
along all right now
I hope no don't be nervous just because
this is your first day everything's
going to be all right but I do hope
nothing goes wrong
oh no Ellie the cream and sugar go down
at this end
I thought incentive ma'am everyone could
reach it amazing mr. Davis is here oh
excuse me I didn't know where to place
the napkins man you can tell put the
Rings the boys have their initials C for
Clarence he sits here J for John here
w-4 quickly
he sits over there next to his father
and the one with a little dog on it is
Harlan's of course he's the baby this
narrow plain one is mine and this is mr.
days it's just like mine except that he
got bent one morning head that reminds
me Annie
always have mr. days coffee piping hot
yes and whatever mr. day speaks to you
just say yes sir don't be nervous
you'll get used to him all that
beautiful rubber plans I'm so glad it
came you mustn't water it every day too
much moisture makes it very unhappy
well good morning mother I thought you
were still upstairs good morning Clara
father must be talking to himself a
redhead did you sleep well mother yes
thank you digger golly I'm hungry
oh and Eddie we over start with fruit in
the morning except the two younger boys
who have their porridge and milk jiminy
another wreck on the New Haven that
always disturbs the stock market father
won't like that
I do wish the New Haven would stop
having wrecks if they knew how it upset
your father my soul and body glance
what's happened to your coat it ripped
open again Margaret mended it for me but
it won't stay mended how do you know
just have to speak to your father about
a new suit of clothes
Clarence why did you take my h2so4 out
of our clothes closet I've told you a
hundred times that cross it's not to
make experiments in too
good morning mother John have you been
making those chemical smells again no
mother I'm making electric battery it'll
ring a bell and everything you know your
father doesn't like electricity
but mother everything's going to be
electricity not in this house Oh what's
the matter Claire what's wrong
where's Monica what's neck tie what I
gave you yesterday
it isn't pressed yet I forgot to give it
to Margaret I Paul you distinctly I
wanted to wear that necktie today you've
got plenty of neckties put on another
one right away and come down to
breakfast I don't know what this world's
coming to
mother may I have my breakfast early I'm
going to play baseball three
wait me before you leave the house you
have to study your catechism but mother
they're going to let me pitch today good
morning
well one giant 7:00 to 3:00 Buck Ewing
at a home run let me see boys don't
wrinkle the paper before your father
sees it mother
could you ask me my catechism now I
think I know it well let's see what is
your name what me Benjamin
who gave you your first tips to come
down long good morning darling
how's your finger it's good that's a
sign it's getting better I'm alone oh
let's see what was I doing
oh yes the Catechism who gave you your
name my sponsors at baptism wherein I
was made a member of Christ the child of
God and an inheritor of the kingdom of
heaven
mother if I hadn't been baptized
wouldn't I have any name not in the
sight of the church what did your
sponsors then for you they did promise
and bow three things in my name first
that I should
[Music]
thirdly that I should keep God's holy
will and commandments and walk in the
same all the days of mine Moni boys
morning morning mini have a good night
yes thank you Claire good turn on boys
what's that thing doing in here yeah
that's our new rubber planet place for
rubber plants is on the equator take an
object out Cap'n you're not Katherine no
good never liked Katherine anyway put it
somewhere else Annie but not too near a
window
are you saying Claire have that new suit
looks very nice
laughter tight you put on a little
weight dear Iowa does the same to always
have well Clarence had just managed to
ruin the only decent [ __ ] hairs I'm
sorry but I'm afraid you need a new suit
of clothes
vini Clarence has to learn not to be so
hard on his clothes but father I thought
I'm starting Yale in the fall you'll be
completely outfitted but nothing the
summer can I have one of your old suits
cut down for me every shoot I own still
has plenty of wear in it I wear my
clothes until they're worn out well do
you want your clothes worn out click the
wear them out much faster than you can
yes and father you never get a chance to
wear yours out every time you get a new
batch of clothes mother sends the old
ones to the missionary barrel I guess
I'm just as good as any old missionary
parents before you compare yourself to a
missionary and remember the sacrifices
they make oh I don't know of any I think
my clothes would look better on Clarence
and on some Hottentot I bet dark socks
you too mine cut down video well thank
you Father what a father suits thank you
sir in return for that Clarence I want
you to practice more often on your
violin Whitney don't eat so fast well
father I'm going to pitch today but
before I go I have to study my catechism
what do you bother with that for because
if he doesn't know his catechism he
can't be confirmed Vinnie what he's
going to pitch today he can be confirmed
any old time class sometimes it seems to
me you don't care whether your children
have to have a no mater oh you'll get to
heaven alright I'll be there before you
are with me I don't see did you get him
and Whitney we get to heaven will
organize a baseball team of our own we
just like you to try and run things up
there like please they could probably
use a good man like me what makes you so
sure they'll let you into heaven well if
they don't I'll certainly raise that
devil of a row Claire I do hope you'll
behave when you get to heaven now Vinnie
what
see how many times have I asked you not
to engage a maid who doesn't know how to
serve properly Claire can't you see
she's new when doing her best how can I
serve myself when she's holding that
platter over my head hold it lower we
came for the one we had yesterday I
don't know why you can't keep a maid oh
you don't
why on earth can't you run your house
the way I run my office all I want is
service that noise Annie who's Annie the
maid I'll take it out
Claire aren't you ashamed of yourself
I don't know you made her cry speaking
to her the way you did I never said a
word to her I was addressing myself to
you I do wish you'd be more careful it's
hard enough to people May than the
uniform just fit this one in the name of
where did you come from
who do you belong to her name is
princess hmm looks more like a prince to
me what's wrong - Margaret this Bacon's
good oh well it's good yes sir Aden
how's that finger come here
ah it's that's healing nicely
I guess you'll know the next time the
cats don't like to be hugged it's
alright to stroke him but don't squeeze
them I'll go back and finish your
oatmeal
I don't like oatmeal go on and finish it
it's good for you I don't like it I'll
tell you what you like and what you
don't like you're not old enough to know
about such things you've no business not
like old meal it's good I hate it that's
enough we won't discuss it
he don't bill at once
yawn that lettuce for your mother I
finish my oatmeal father ma'am excuse
yes Whitney here we go it's a good game
with me
yes mother my catechism never mind this
morning darling run alone thank you
mother
what's wanted Margaret what is this
coffee sir it is not coffee
you couldn't possibly take water and
coffee beans and arrived at that it's
slops that's what it is slops take it
away I come down to this table every
morning hungry and if you're hungry
Claire why aren't you eating your
breakfast
I am aunt Judith wants me to come up and
visit her knobby knee I want no more
relatives in this house we are going to
live here by ourselves in peace and
comfort layer I was saying aunt Judith
wants me to visit her Oh eat your
oatmeal tea here what on earth is this
dear friend day we are assigning you the
exclusive rights to Staten Island for
selling the gem home papa popcorn I
think that's for me Father but then why
isn't it addressed to clarence day June
yer oh it is I wouldn't get mixed up in
popcorn Clarence it's too wind
adjustable if you please ma'am listen
Dollard you and a package it's Lewis and
Congress oh yes those kitchen knives I
ordered make a Memorandum of that Vinnie
one dollar and whatever it was for
record of what is spent running this
house I've never understood what good a
record is after the money's gone there's
just a dollar Margaret Vinnie this house
must be run on a business basis of
course dear that's what the household
accounts are for oh Claire it's half
past eight you don't want to be late as
he always time any clear the table now
Clarence John yes you boys go up and
move the small bureau from our room into
your who's coming cousin Cora and she's
bringing a friend with it a young girl a
girl you would have to help entertain
her clothes Oh mother do I have to wait
till father finds out we've got visitors
they'll be rappers John don't criticise
your father he's very hospitable after
he gets used to the idea I like coffee I
like she I like the girls and the girls
like me I don't like girls and they
don't like me oh come on Claire what's
wrong
how did that get in this room now Claire
how was the new maid - no keep that
abomination out of here oh Claire dear
I'm afraid I'm going to need some more
money you were complaining about the
coffee this morning
well that nice French drip coffee pot is
broken you know how it got broken never
mind that Vinnie as I remember that
coffee pot cost $5 and something I'll
give you $6 when you get it Vinnie enter
the exact amount in the ledger of course
we can't the one month a month having
the household accounts is such a mess no
and I thought of a system that will make
my bookkeeping perfect well I'm
certainly relieved to hear that all we
have to do is open charge accounts
everywhere and the stores will do my
bookkeeping for me now wait a minute
minute then when the bills come in you'd
know exactly where your money had gone
hell I certainly would Vinnie we get
enough pillows as it is Claire dear
don't you hate those arguments we have
every month I certainly do
not to have those I should think would
be worth something to you
well I'd open an account Louis and
congas and one of my queries to start
with Thank You Claire which yard works
out thank you oh the rector is coming to
tea today well I'm glad you warned me
I'll go to the club don't expect me home
and we're gonna divert Claire dear I do
wish you take a little more interest in
the church getting me into heaven is
your business Vinnie if there's anything
wrong with my ticket when I get there
you can fix it up everybody loves you so
much I'm sure God must - I'll do my best
Claire it wouldn't be heaven without you
you're there have any I'll manage to get
in some way even if I have to climb the
fence
sweet baby Margaret Margaret Claire
what's wrong why did God make so many
dumb fools and Democrats Oh politics
yes but it's taking the bread out of our
mouths honest Hugh Grant honest ah fine
mayor you've turned out to be if you
can't run this city without raising
taxes every five minutes you'd better
get out let someone who can
Richard cookers running in this town and
you're just his cat's paw tell me this
are these increased taxes going into
public improvements or are they going
into graft answer me that honestly if
you can mister honest Hugh Grant
you can't I thought so you were elected
to office on the promise that you would
put an end while this thievery and
corruption have you put him into it no
you've encouraged some new raid on the
public treasure we're going to throw you
and your boodle Board of Aldermen out of
office I'm warning you for the last time
robbery that's what it is highway
robbery any cup of coffee into mr. day
we make you a good round someone to
watch after our interests and all we get
is inefficiency I know you're a
nincompoop
and I strongly suspect you of being a
scalawag
you're not going to escape your legal
responsibilities legal responsibilities
by God I mean criminal responsibilities
don't think for one minute we're gonna
to escape we're going to throw you into
jail
Danny are you hurt you can't throw me
into jail
any why can't I have quiet here in the
morning now what happened sounded means
though that may drop the whole tray of
dishes what did you say to her say [ __ ]
I haven't seen her since breakfast
I better get the office oh yes Claire
you don't want to be late I'll be home
in plenty of time for dinner why don't
we have chicken fricassee tonight well
clear you cans gone up it's eight cents
a pound
[Music]
she going dressed up like that say aye
you've done it again
how could you could I what can't you see
she's leaving dear I have no time to
engage in you mate we'll have to have
dinner out in her out nonsense
I'll engage new made myself no you can't
she has to get beyond the thorns I have
one here in an hour
good morning mr. annoying
we're mr. danger
yeah
[Music]
let me I declare you're getting younger
and prettier everyone Mary Skinner and
Skinner's daughter Mike I never would
have known you just leave your things
out here and come right off him I talk
so much about you know how he used to
dip my pigtails in the info box
Oh What's in you was in Pleasantville
Cora Oh Vinny I have so much to tell you
we wrote you that act Harry broke her
hip yeah that was the night that Robert
Ingersoll lectured of course she
couldn't get there but was a good thing
for mr. Ingersol she did how do you do
cousin Cora oh this is John John why how
you've grown you'll be a man before your
mother
John this is Mary Skinner how do you do
how do you do
Vinny everybody in Pleasantville sends
their love grandpa Everts cousin Edith
aunt Hattie that Arizona if there is
grandpa oh he hasn't met at all well you
know he only has one kidney and that's
floating how do you do cousin Cora I'm
glad to see you
this can't be Clara yes my my my
goodness every time I see you boys you
grown another foot let's see you're
going to st. Paul's now aren't you st.
Paul's I was through with st. Paul's
long ago I'm starting in Yale this fall
yeah Oh Oh Mary this is Clarence and
Mary Skinner how do you do it this is
Mary's first trip to New York yes it is
it's her first trip you'll have to show
Mary around I tell you I'll ask mr. day
to take us all to Delmonico's for dinner
tonight no Monica think of that Mary
Delmonico's and cousin Claire such a
wonderful home when I know you girls
want to freshen up so come upstairs
Clarence give their bags I've given you
girls Clarence's room but he didn't know
about it I don't get there all
bags oh you play the violin well I I
fool whether a middle you're just being
modest no really I I play the piano not
awfully well now you're being modest
do you ever play duets well I haven't up
to now neither have i up to now Cora
didn't tell me about you I never met a
Yale man before what's happened to you
nothing I feel fine
[Music]
are you people do you wish a domestic
servant where do you keep them I will
take your name and address I'm falling
I'm late at the office now if you will
give me the details as to what kind of
person you require I'm asking you where
you keep them but plants are not allowed
in that room if you will tell me the
kind of a position you wish to have
filled just antifreeze sir this is quite
against the rules I must know what you
want the girl for I'll take that one
what's your name yes sir
illa you go right over to 420 Madison
Avenue I will sir
that's all thank you sir before I can
let any girl go from this establishment
I must know the character of the home in
which he will be employed madam I am the
character of my home my duty toward my
neighbor is to love him as myself and to
do unto all men as they should do unto
me as they should do unto me - he really
knows it well he's done very well for so
young a boy may I go now yes darling
thank you dr. Lloyd how are you and mr.
day must be very proud of your children
I was hoping I'd find mr. day at home
this afternoon well he's usually home
from the office by this time perhaps
he's gone for a gallop in the park it's
such a fine day he's very fond of
horseback riding I believe oh yes
goodnight has he ever been thrown from a
horse
oh no no horse would throw mr. day I
just thought he might have had some
accident I notice he never kneels in
church oh that's no accident but I don't
want you to think he doesn't pray he
does why sometimes you can hear him all
over the house but he never kneels
perhaps that's mr. day now
I hardly think so oh the devil Africa
come here and you're just in time
fatigue out simple some hot water how
are you dr. Lloyd mother
are they back yet no Clarence no except
for a brief glimpse on the sever I don't
see much of you devilishly visit a very
busy day tire out hahaha how a man can
get tired just sitting at a desk all day
I don't know I suppose Wall Street is
just as much a mystery to you as it is
to me dr. Lowe I didn't know no it's all
very clear to me my mind often goes to
the businessman the picture I'm most
fond on is when I envision him at the
close of the day's work I see him
pausing in his toil and it comes over
him that all those figures of profit and
loss are without importance or
consequence vanity and yes I'll be Flair
yes ma'am Delia some more hot water
please yes who's that do you mean
where's the one I sent this morning the
uniform didn't fit I like the one I
picked out better
clear dr. Lloyd wants to tell us about
the plans for the new edifice and you
what the new church you knew we were
planning to build a new church of course
we're going to have to raise a large sum
money
well personally I am against the church
hop skipping and jumping all over the
town so any contribution I make will
have to be a small one the amount
everyone is to subscribe has already
been decided who decided it after
considerable thought we voted that our
supporting members should each
contributor some equal to the cost of
their pew I paid $5,000 for my pew yes
Claire that makes our contribution
$5,000 that's robbery do you know what
that view was worth today $3,000 that's
what the last one sold for I've taken a
dead loss of $2,000 on a few already
Frank bags
mean that Pew and the marketers at his
peak he knew when to get out and I'm
warning you Vinnie yeah the market ever
goes up I'm going to unload that Pew
Clarence day how can you speak of the
temple of the Lord as though it was
something to be bought and sold on Wall
Street now mrs. day your husband is a
practical man we've had to be practical
about the new church we have all the
facts and figures Oh what's the property
where we are now
oh let's see is it $40,000 I know the
figure has a 4 in it what's the new
piece of property going to cost you I
think the figure I heard mentioned was
$85,000 or was it a hundred and eighty
five thousand dr. Lloyd you preach that
someday we'll all have to answer to God
we shall indeed well I hope God doesn't
ask you any questions what's figures in
them it's custom Cora she's passing
through town well hello come Mary Oh
Vinny what a day
we've been in every shop in town why
cousin Claire oh you're as welcome as
the flowers in Maine this is Mary
Skinner mr. day how do you do
I've been telling Mary all about you
she's been dying to meet you dr. Lloyd I
want you to meet my favorite cousin miss
Cartwright Skinner dr. Lloyd this seems
to be a family reunion I'll just run
along goodbye dr. Lloyd do you do to dr.
Lloyd goodbye doctor my goodbye
everybody go to the door with you thank
you so much fatigue who did you say this
pretty little girl is she said Skinner's
daughter this is Mary's first trip to
New York oh sit down sit down have some
tea we had tea downtown
never mind them that snaps it down even
if you have had tea you can stay and
visit for a while as a matter of fact
why don't you both stay to dinner
that's all arranged Claire coronary are
going to have a dinner with us
fine fine of course you just have to
take potluck well I'd hardly call air
did you know the girls are going to
visit apps Judith in Springfield for our
home mom fine how long you're going to
be in New York corner all week
splendid we hope to see something audio
when you certainly well Cora it did you
find anything you wanted in the shop oh
I can't wait to show you oh but I'm
afraid some of these packages can't be
open in front of cousin Claire shall I
leave the room or should I say your room
wasn't it nice of players to give up his
room to us for a whole week
Cora come on I just can't wait to see
what's in those packages we'll be back
soon
I wish to speak to you before you what
Stan I'll be down in just a minute
Claire I wish to speak to you now I'll
be up in just a minute Cora it's all
right Vinny come along Mary those two
women encamped in our house I'm a-gonna
Claire you know me just admit it
Clarence
how Claire you know you've always been
fond of Korra what to do with her
thanking yourself down in my house and
bringing all the strangers with her how
can you call that sweet little girl a
horde of strangers why don't they go to
a hotel New York is full of hotels built
for the express purpose of housing such
nuisances here two girls alone than a
hotel but who knows what might happen to
them all right then put them on the
first train they want to roll the
gypsies lend him a hand
keep him roaming staying in that little
room of Clarence's the trouble is they
don't stay there they stay in the
bathroom every time I want to take my
bath it's full of giggling females
washing her hair I tell I won't have it
send em to hotel I'll pay the bill
gladly but get them out of here father
I'm afraid they can hear you upstairs
keep those doors closed Clarence you
open those doors open them all the way
now Claire you be quiet and behave
yourself they're here and they're going
to stay here
that's enough Vinnie I want no more of
this argument
Oh try but I don't understand is why the
swarm of locusts always descends on us
without any warning ow
Thunder Vinnie
dear Vinnie
[Music]
[Music]
father may I go along with the rest of
you to Delmonico's
what's that Delmonico's you're taking
mother cousin Cora and miss give it to
Delmonico's for dinner tonight
[Music]
I won't I won't have it I will not have
my life arranged for me I bought this
house for my own card
I would not submit myself to this
indignity do I understand that I am not
permitted to have dinner in my own home
a little change will do you're God I
have home to have dinner in and any time
I can't have dinner at home this house
is for sale well Claire you can't have
dinner here tonight because it isn't
ordered
and besides Cora Mary well to see
something of New York
well that's no affair of mine I am NOT a
guy to Chinatown and the Bowery
Oh mr. day I just love your house
I could live here forever chorus waiting
for you mrs. day oh yes I revita
[Music]
I'm glad you like our house miss Skinner
I like it very much mr. de três from a
stranger is approbation indeed at whom
our living room is green I like green I
like green too Reds my favorite color
it's an interesting thing about colors
Reds a nice color in a house too but
outside too much red would be bad I mean
for instance if all the trees and the
grass were written outside greens the
best color that's right but when you do
think of it it's quite a thought I bet
you make your market yeah oh my mother
wants me to go to college do you believe
in girls going to college I guess it's
all right if they want to waste that
much time before they get married I mean
I'm glad you're funny
music mr. day oh hello what can you use
companion John enjoys the youths
companion John don't you sit down oh
thank you it tells all about connecting
batteries in series John
miss Skinner and I were talking oh
that's all right you won't bother me
jiminee that's where I made my mistake I
didn't mix enough
oh don't start can you play that I'm
afraid not
can you pray sweet Genevieve that's my
favorite not without my music he was in
height don't you think I like this one
[Music]
that's funny the words are the same but
it's the wrong tune oh it can't be the
wrong - and we sing it exactly that way
in church we don't think it that way in
the Methodist Church
you see we're Methodists oh that's too
bad
well I don't mean it's too bad that
you're a Methodist anybody's got a right
to be anything they want but what I mean
is where Episcopalians yes I know
anyway the words are the same shall we
begin
now
[Music]
what's wrong shall we try again
[Music]
must be my fault oh no it's my fault
no you are the Episcopalian I just
remembered something my father wasn't
Episcopalian he was baptized in the
Pisgah Padian he wasn't Episcopalian
right up to the time he married my
mother she was the Methodist oh oh well
let's try it again then well Clarence if
you're going to Delmonico's with us
you'd better get rest am I going to
Jimmy thank you Father
be ready in just a minute brother Vinnie
that young lady looks about the same age
you were when I came out to present bill
to rescue you rescue me
you came out there to talk me into
marrying you it worked out just the same
[Music]
Francois we we that is your bombers your
day let me see LSU's
let me see this year she can talk mushy
squash that is better suited for thanks
no cookie like the French Claire was so
nice of you to invite coronary here that
first night it's been a pleasure mr. day
have you always been an Episcopalian
I've always gone to the Episcopal Church
yes but you weren't baptized to
Methodist or anything where are you you
were baptized in Episcopalian come to
think of it I don't believe I will have
a baptized at all
Claire that's not very funny joking
about a subject like that I'm not joking
I remember now I never was baptized yeah
that's ridiculous everybody's baptized
what I'm not no one would keep a little
baby from being baptized you know father
or mother we think as both of them they
felt their children should decide those
things for themselves but cool I
remember when I was 10 or 12 years old
mother set out to give some thought to
it but I never got around to how to get
done for me do you know what you're
saying yes I'm saying I've never been
baptized something's got to be done
about it right away
oh pretty don't get excited over nothing
why haven't you ever told me what
difference does it make I have never
heard of anyone who wasn't baptized even
the savages in darkest Africa it's
alright for savages and Shirin but if an
oversight was made in my case it's too
late to correct it now
[Music]
what if you're not baptized you're not a
Christian I can't found it of course I'm
Christian a mighty good Christian - a
lot better Christian and those some
singers in church but you can't be if
you won't be baptized I won't be
baptized and I will be a Christian I'll
be a Christian in my own way clear don't
you what to make us all in heaven of
course and I'm going to are all day no
but you must being like that you're
coming to church with me before you go
to the office in the morning and be
baptized then and there Benny don't be
ridiculous if you think I'm going to
stand there and let dr. Lloyd splash
water on me at my age you're mistaken
no I'm sleepy
good night Benny
[Music]
yes if father hasn't been baptized he
hasn't any name and the site of the
church he hasn't any name that's right
maybe we're not even married we thine
unworthy servants do give the most
humble and hearty thanks for all that
goodness and loving kindness to us and
to all men we bless thee for our
creation preservation and all the
blessings of this life but above all for
thine inestimable love in the redemption
of the world by our Lord Jesus Christ
for the means of grace for the hope of
glory and we beseech thee give us that
new sense of all thy mercies that our
hearts may be
the grace of our Lord Jesus Christ and
the love of God and the Fellowship of
the Holy Ghost be with us all evermore
[Music]
so my friends what comforted security it
gives us when we have reached the age of
understanding to know that the Rite of
baptism has not been neglected in our
infancy or you can you imagine any man
who has reached maturity with the
knowledge that he had never been
baptized failing the hastened of the
holy font that his soul might be saved
as it says in the baptismal office
except a man be born of water and of the
spirit he cannot enter into the kingdom
of God he that believeth and is baptized
shall be saved but he that believeth not
shall be damned
what's that follow-up - he can't be
which also shows us the great anything
he's baptized for the promise is to you
and to your children dokie not therefore
but earnestly believe
the name of the Father and of the Son
and of the Holy Ghost army
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
mrs. William Tyler ricochet
this is Wilhemina Eugenia Wickersham
what a lovely day for betwee baptized
happiest day in my life
[Music]
there you know I didn't ask dr. Lloyd to
do what you must have said something
well I had to find out from him if we
were really married I am married and I'm
not baptized and as far as I'm concerned
the whole congregation can know it they
certainly know it now excuse me I don't
go to church to be preached out as
though I were some lost sheep you don't
seem to understand what the church is
for then hit this one place the church
should leave alone it's a man's soul
[Applause]
well he's going to be baptized Cora you
mark my word I just couldn't go to
heaven without Claire why I get lonesome
for him even when I go to Ohio it's
awfully hard on a woman to love a man
like Claire so much Oh men are so
aggravating they take everything for
granted they certainly do you know I
don't believe Claire's come right out
and told me he loves me since we've been
married
of course I know it does because I keep
reminding him of it you have to keep
reminding them Cora we're having it
after core of Mary go to the train left
I was coming at one-o'clock cab the
horse cars go right past the door but
Claire they have those heavy bags abs
are waste of money
well if dinner is going to be delayed
I'll work on this month's bills
what are they now Claire it isn't fair
to go over the household accounts when
you're hungry
Vinnie where are those bills they're in
the library on your desk no dinner was
going to be late back home I ride over
time I know their horse is my favorite
animal oh my goodness where have you two
been
Karen's wanted to show me his
grandfather's house you will have to
hurry and finish your packing he won't
take me laughs can I help you pack
Clarence Clarence
why don't you kneel in church today all
right I just couldn't if it's because
your father doesn't reel you must
remember he wasn't brought up to kneel
in church but you were has it anything
to do with Mary I know she's a leaveners
oh no mother Methodist no Mary told me
they don't get up-and-down so much but
they stay down longer Clarence you want
a deal don't you oh yes I wanted to
kneel today I tried you saw me try but I
just couldn't is that suitable your
father's so tight for you no it's not
too tight what is it mother very
peculiar things have happened to me
since I started to wear this suit I
can't seem to make these clothes do
anything father wouldn't do that's
nonsense Clarence now to kneel in church
is a sacrilege making Father's trousers
and he'll seem more of a sacrilege
Clarence do you know what happened to
dura Wakefield's party for Mary last
night we were playing musical chairs and
some girl sat down suddenly right in my
floor I jumped up so fast she almost got
hurt she was sitting on father's
trousers well mother I've got to have a
suit of my own nice old embody well
you'll just have to talk to your father
about it
I'm sure if you approach him the right
way you'll know tactfully he'll see oh
it excuse me gracious it didn't take you
very long well I'll see about your box
lunch for the train remember it's Sunday
I I was hoping we could have a few
minutes together before you left
Cora had so much to do I wanted to get
out of her way
well didn't you want to see me I did
want to tell you how much I enjoyed our
friendship Oh wha mother told us to sit
in the living room till dinner's ready
have you ever been out on our porch oh
yeah well let me show it to you
[Music]
it's awfully hard to grow up in a family
with children my I've never known a
waiting to pass so quickly why I why I
you're going to write me when you get to
Springfield aren't you of course if you
write me first but you'll have something
to write about your trip and aunt Judith
and how things aren't spring for you you
write me as soon as you get there maybe
I'll be too busy maybe I won't have time
well you find the time let's not have
any nonsense about that you write me
first and you'll do it right away the
first day how do you know I'll take
orders from you
well sure you give me your hand why
should give me your hand confound it
[Music]
what are you thinking about I was just
thinking about what I was hoping you'd
write me first because that would mean
you lie to me
what's my writing first got to do with
liking you you do like me then of course
I do I like you better than any girl I
ever met
[Music]
but you don't like me well enough to
ride first well I don't see how one
thing's got anything to do with the
other what a girl can't ride first
because because she's a girl
well that's nonsense if a girl has
something to write about in a fellow
hasn't there's no reason why she
shouldn't write first you know the first
few days I was here you do anything for
and then you changed you used to be a
lot of fun then all of a sudden you
turned into an old sober sides but why
are you even dressed like an old sober
sides it just happened to remember
something Barry please but Clarence
we'll see each other in a month when I
come back please ride me first because
that'll show me how much you please how
do you how much I like you
get up get up don't do that oh no no
it's not that
oh is it because it's Sunday no it'd be
the same any day like young ladies
crying she's in tears what's the meaning
of this I'm sorry father it's all my
fault
nonsense what's that girl trying to do
to you no no she wasn't it was I
whatever the quarrel was about parents
I'm glad you held your own
father I have to have a new suit of
clothes you've got to give me the money
for it young man do you realize that
you're addressing your father I'm sorry
father I apologize but you don't know
how important this is to me a new suit
of clothes is so important oh why should
Clarence has your need for a new suit of
clothes anything to do with that young
lady yes Father
Clarence what this comes as quite a
shock to me what does father are you
were being so grown-up
still I might have known if you are
going to college this fall yes you're at
the age when you'll be meeting girls
Clarence there are things about women
that I think you ought to know sit down
yes I think it's better for you to hear
this for me than to have to learn it for
yourself that's women aren't the Angels
that you think they are
well now first let me explain this to
you
you see Clarence we men have to run this
world and it's not an easy job it takes
work and it takes thinking
a man has to reason things out now you
take a woman a woman thinks no I'm wrong
right there a woman doesn't think at all
she gets stirred up and she gets stirred
up over the most confounding things now
I love my wife just as much as any man
but that doesn't mean that I should
stand for a lot of father all my god I
won't stand for it stand for what father
that's the one thing I shall not submit
myself to Clarence if a man thinks a
certain thing is wrong he shouldn't do
it
if he thinks it's right he should do it
now that has nothing to do with whether
he loves his wife or not
who says it has father they do women
they get stirred up and then they try to
get you stirred up too but don't you let
them do it Clarence don't you let them
do it now if you can keep reason and
logic in the argument but a man can hold
his own cause but if they can switch you
pretty soon the arguments about whether
you love them or not I swear I don't
know how they do it but don't you let
them Clarence don't you let them I see
what you mean so far father if you don't
watch yourself
love can make you do a lot of things you
don't want to do exactly but if you do
watch out and know just how to handle
women then you'll be alright all a man
has to do is be firm you know how
sometimes I have to be firm with your
mother yes but father what can you do
when they cry mmm
well that's quite a question you just
have to make them understand that what
you're doing is for their good I see
our planets you know all about women but
father yes Baroness I thought you were
going to tell me about about what about
women
Clarence there are some things gentlemen
don't discuss I told you all you need to
know the thing for you to remember is be
far
[Music]
marry when you get to Springfield the
very first thing you
[Music]
oh sit down Vinny can their coronary
leaving any moment now
Vinny you know I like to live well
and I want my family to live well but
this house must be run on a business
basis I must know how much money I'm
spending and what for for instance if
you recall a week ago I gave you 6
dollars to buy a new copy mine yes
because you broke the old one you throw
it right on the floor I'm not talking
about that now I find me to break that
nice coffee pot Claire it was imported
from France and that little shop has
stopped selling them but what her study
but the tariffs wouldn't bless them and
that's your fault because you're always
voting to raise the tariff tariff
protects America against cheap foreign
labor now this bill tariff does nothing
but put up the prices and that's hard on
everybody especially the farmer Vinnie I
wish to heaven you wouldn't talk about
matters you don't know anything about I
don't know about them mister yulux
there's that every intelligent woman
should have some of him may I ask is
Miss Gillick she's the current events
woman I told you that and the tickets
are $1 every Tuesday do you mean to tell
me that a pack of idle minded females
pay $1 apiece to hear another female
gavel about the events of the day listen
to me if you want to know anything about
the events of the day what do you get so
excited Claire and besides miss kulick
says that our president whom you're
always belittling praise to God for that
Vinnie what happened to that six dollars
what six dollars I gave you six dollars
to buy a new coffee pot now I find that
you apparently got one of us in Congress
and charged it here's their bill one
coffee pot five dollars so you owe me a
dollar and you can hand it right over
I'll do nothing of the kind
what did you do with that six dollars
well Claire I can't tell you now dear
why didn't you ask me at the time
wait a minute I spent $4 and a half for
that new one Brella now we're getting
something one umbrella four dollars and
fifty cents that must have been the week
I paid mrs. Tobin for two extra days
washing mrs. Tobin that's $2 more that
makes that makes up six dollars and
fifty cents and that's another fifty
cents you owe me I don't owe you
anything what you owe me is an
explanation of where my money is gone I
do the best I can to keep down expenses
you know yourself cousin Phoebe spends
twice as much as we do don't talk to me
about your cousin Phoebe you talk about
your own relatives enough
that's not fair Vinnie when I talk about
my relatives I criticize them I can't
even speak of cousin Phoebe you can
speak about all you want to but I won't
have cousins DB or anyone else dictating
for me out at my house I didn't say a
word about her dictating Claire you know
she isn't that you said you said I don't
know what you said now you never stick
to the point
now we're going over this account book
item by item I find here a bill for $38
I don't know what you expected me I tie
myself out chasing up and down those
stairs all day long trying to look after
your comfort to bring up our children
I do the mending and the marketing now
you want me to be an expert okay
Vinny I want to be reasonable but can't
you understand I'm doing all this for
your own good
oh well I suppose I'll have to go ahead
just paying the bills and hoping I've
got enough money in the bank to meet
them that's all very discouraging I'll
try to do better Claire well that's all
I'm asking well I will it make out the
chicks side them but maybe I haven't any
right to sign those checks since in the
sight of the Lord I haven't any name
that's right
Claire to make those checks good you
don't have to be baptized right away
Vinny the bank doesn't care whether I've
been baptized or not well I care and no
matter what dr. Lloyd said I'm not sure
we're really married Vinnie we have four
children if we're not married now we
never will be this morning uh why don't
you better go tell her what need to
watch for the cab not before you give me
that dollar nass dollar and a half you
owe me I don't owe you any dollar and a
half I gave you money to buy a coffee
pot for me and somehow it turned into an
umbrella for you Clarence day what kind
of man are you
quibbling about a dollar and a half when
your immortal soul is in danger and
what's more all right all right thank
you Kay now the accounts are all
straight again
[Music]
what were you doing down there I'm
setting up this new burglar alarm I
invented it myself have you got any
money you can let me know you owe me 30
cents now I'll give you my stamp
collection of my piece of John Wilkes
Booth's finger
how much enough to get a new suit of
clothes if you can wait a month till I
heard him the Patent Office in
Washington I may be rich I can't wait
that long
maybe I could get it sooner I'm gonna
look into something else tomorrow
wanted an energetic young man to sell
household necessity liberal commission
applied 3:12 what John let me have this
job why should I give you my job they're
hard to get I've got to get a new suit
of clothes maybe I could get the job for
both of us I'll ask the man the cab to
your father
oh thank you Whitney evany Cora
John go up and get their bags yes sir
here's the lunch for the train sir take
it out to the cab who's that one it's
Alan Delia nap yesterday I don't know
where your mother finds them no Vinnie
don't you let Claire worry about us we
have plenty of time Oh take the bags
right on out John well good-bye cause it
was so nice to see you goodbye quickly
now you see a good boy goodbye heartland
goodbye keep out of mischief along
everybody don't keep the cab waiting
perhaps cost money if there's one thing
mr. day can't stand it's to keep a cab
waiting are you waiting to do there's a
waiting room at the Grand Central Depot
just for that Mary aren't you even going
to shake hands with me I don't think I'd
better
you may remember when I get too close to
you you feel contaminated Mary you're
going to write to me aren't you are you
going to write first no Mary there are
times when a man must be firm Mary
mother says you better hurry out before
father starts yelling it's Sunday
goodbye John I'm very happy to have made
your acquaintance thank you may I help
you
no thank you goodbye Mary goodbye cousin
Claire goodbye Clara goodbye Korra
[Music]
dear Mary my duty toward my neighbor
just to love him ask myself and to do to
all men as I would they should do it to
me
has father gone to the office yet come
on let's go to the ball field I've got
to guard this box though John comes back
it's his burglar alarm
it wouldn't work so I fixed it we're
going to put it back in the dining room
after father goes to the office and
there are burglars around everywhere to
love honor and succor my father and my
mother why do you have to learn that
because if I don't I'll go to hell
fathers going to hell yes not yes he is
because he isn't baptized he'll go to
hell and burn for a thousand years you
out he will be in a lake of fire and
brimstone in a Thousand Devils with
pitchforks
[Music]
boys just singing father you boys be
quiet you know your mother isn't feeling
well yes Father
what did your mother say she said she
doesn't want any breakfast oh why does
your mother do that to me
you know what upsets my day when she
doesn't come down to breakfast
especially delivery say thank you
where's John this morning John had his
breakfast early father and went out to
see about something co-op what well John
and I thought we'd work this summer and
earn some money
good work never hurt anyone it's good
for them what are you going to work work
hard
think Solomon had the right idea about
work whatever thy hand find us to do
Solomon said do thy dog honest well I
don't understand this at all there's a
letter from some woman I never even
heard of Oh father don't God what is it
father this woman claims that she sat on
my lap and then I didn't like it huh
what's that word no that one down there
looks like curiosity I only opened your
letter as a matter of curiosity yes go
on why this gets worse and worse it just
turns into a lot of sentimental
lovey-dovey mush this is someone's idea
of a practical joke what's the matter
Claire what's wrong nothing wrong that's
a fool letter how are you feeling Vinnie
I thought you needed me if you don't
I'll go back to bed come sit down and
get some food in you do your board build
up your strength
sit down sit down yeah what's this one's
name Nora Nora get mrs. de some bacon
and eggs no bring me a cup of tea up to
my room yes ma'am Vinnie
it's just weak to give in to an ailment
I noticed when you have a headache you
yell and groan and swearing up well
let's approve to the headache that I am
stronger than it is I think I've caught
some kind of germ some of my friends
have had to send for the doctor dr. Paul
poppycock
but Claire dear when people are ill you
have to do something certainly have to
do something zero up that's way to cure
him how would you go about cheering them
up I thought I'd come what have I done
oh oh Claire
[Music]
Hey I didn't mean to upset you
[Music]
you're crazy
[Music]
I was just trying to help you you know
when you take your bed I have a
confounded lonely time around here so
when I see you hitting it into your head
that you're not feeling well I want to
do something about it just because some
of your friends are given into this no
reason why you should imagine your
[Music]
[Music]
did you get the job yes for both of us
look I've got with me
what is it medicine medicine you took a
job for us to go out and sell medicine
it's wonderful medicine what it cures a
sovereign cure for coals
coughs guitar asthma Quincy and sore
throat for the jetsons summer complaint
colic dyspepsia heartburn and shortness
of breath lumbago rheumatism heart
disease giddiness and women's complaints
nervous prostration Saint Vitus dance
jaundice 'la grip proud flesh pink I see
sickness and pimples it's made from a
secret formula known only to dr.
Bartlett we get 25 cents Commission on
every bottle we sell and he's giving us
the territory of all Manhattan Island
lots of fathers and mothers friends have
some of those diseases let's start out
by calling on their yes Oh what if they
ask us if we use it at our house yes it
would be better if we could say we did
excuse me
oh is that the tea for mrs. day yeah
well I'll take it up to her oh thank you
right away now why did Todd what's the
matter with mother I don't know she was
just complaining say it says here it's
good for women's complaints here
yes sir Chesapeake and Ohio in a new
york central 3/4 I'd like to see mr.
Dave out there's more in Essex
have you come to pay us a visit
where's father busy in his office with a
customer mr. Whitney you have to come
home right away what's the meaning of
this who sent you down yeah your mother
no sir mother sale she's terribly ill
did the doctor sent you for me
no sir it was Margaret Margaret Margaret
says you're to come home right away uh
no nonsense Perkins go down and stop the
first cab you seen cab sir are you mr.
day yes I want to cap a no-nonsense I'm
sorry but the Hawkins
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
Oh doctor how is mrs. de she's a pretty
sick woman what's wrong with her
well do you know her don't you what did
mrs. de have for breakfast this morning
not a thing I tried to get a read so I
think she wouldn't I can't understand it
I understand what these violent attacks
of nausea it's almost as though she were
poisoned poisoned let me take your cab
I'll try not to be gone more than 10 to
15 minutes and mr. day you are not to go
into a room you'd better get her well
right away or you'll hear from me turn
west on 27th Street how is mother
I don't know well she better be good and
sick her father may be mad at me for
getting him up here especially in a cab
does she found the comb yes just now
where you going my wreck I have to go
for the minister I guess the minister's
coming to baptize fathers so I won't
have to go to hell it can't be baptized
in a house you've got to have water we
have lots of water not the right kind
there's mother better father how could I
tell she wouldn't let me in the room
with that he's kind of found abductors
never know what's the matter with
anybody
father yes mother is going to get well
isn't she
of course she's gonna get well father
may we come in its water without mother
yes it is Harlem it's a long summer come
in boys what are you doing stairs what
about you Whitney
I was supposed to learn the rest of my
catechism will you hear me Father
yes Whitney I'd hear you start here how
many parts are there in a sacrament to
the outward visible sign and the inward
spiritual grace
what is the outward visible sign or form
in BAP baptism water wherein the person
is baptized in the name of you haven't
been baptized have your father with me
what is the outward visible sign water
where in the person you don't know it
well enough Whitney you'd better go and
study it some more do you want me to
read to you Hana father are they gonna
put you into hell what need they call
him with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
coming to their everybody's selling
better doctors doctors don't do you any
good make you feel worse mr. D we must
I'll be quiet
mrs. Dave's video I know she's a cop and
see if she needs anything what are you
doing out of house sent for the minister
the minister he'd be right in he's
paying off the cat I was deeply shocked
to learn the serious nature of mrs.
Daisy illness will you take me up to her
she's resting how she can't be disturbed
the doctor will be back in a minute mrs.
day has been a tower of strength in the
parish everyone liked her so much
yes she was a fine woman I wish to
heaven you wouldn't talk about mrs. day
as if she were dead
if the doctor back yet no does she need
him well she's kind of restless she's
talking in her sleep and twisting and
turning
laughter it seems to me that was a
pretty long 10 minutes see here mr. day
if I'm to handle this case how can you
handle if you're out of the house who is
this
it's dr. summers how do you do I felt
that mrs. days condition warranted my
getting dr. summers hair as soon as
possible for consultation I hope that
meets with your approval oh yes of
course anything that can be done
upstairs doctor
mrs. J is in good hands now mr. day
there's nothing you and I can do at the
moment to help dr. Boyd
yes there's something that's troubling
mrs. days mind oh I think you know what
i referred yes you mean the fact that
you've never been baptized yes I
gathered that you knew about it from
your sermon last Sunday but let's not
get angry I think something had better
be done father
yes mr. day when the doctors get through
up there I want you to talk to mrs. day
I want you to tell her something why I'd
be glad to you're just the man to do it
she shouldn't be upset about this I want
you to tell her that my being baptized
would just be a lot of confounded
nonsense but mr. day no she take you a
word on a thing like that and we both
must do everything we can to help her
now but the solution is so simple it
would take only your consent to be
baptized that's out of the question and
I'm surprised that a grown man like you
would suggest such a thing
well doctor how is she what have you
decided
is there a room we could use for our
consultation oh yes my library doctor
dr. summers this isn't serious is it
after we've had our consultation will
you talk to us today but shorting rest
assure dr. Summers will do everything it
is humanly possible we'll try not to be
locked
[Music]
tell me this doctor sauce he's very
highly thought of as oh yes lavinius
seriously if anyone could help her he
could how do you think very fine
physician but there is a greater health
ever-present in the hour of need let us
turn to him in prayer let us kneel and
pray let us kneel and pray
Oh Lord look down from heaven the whole
visit and relieve this thy servant who
is grieved with sickness have mercy on
her oh lord have mercy on this miserable
sinner forgive her and extend I have
custom she's not a miserable sinner and
you know it Oh God you know videos not a
miserable sinner she's a fine woman
she shouldn't be maker Saba it's good to
stop I tell you it's not to stop have
mercy I say how mercy I tell you what's
the matter what's wrong
Jenny honey what are you doing down here
you shouldn't be out of bed you get
right back upstairs I heard you call do
you need me Vinnie I know now how much I
need you get well Vinnie I'll be
baptized I promise I'll be baptized I'll
do anything
Oh we'll go to Europe just we too
you won't have to worry about the
children were the household accounts Oh
Vinnie don't worry miss today she'll be
all right now bless you for what you
have done what I do you promised to be
baptized I did Oh God
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's not drafting here mother shall I
get your coat mother don't say he won't
stay cool and quite comfortable thank
you come on now let's stay together
Holland don't you get lost again are the
hats lovely this year ostrich feathers
you wouldn't wear that how would you
mother I think that's very pretty I
think they're all pretty I do need some
tips oh cool oh isn't this applicable
just arrived from Paris madam it's
charming what are you looking for mother
I think I just take a plain one but this
is the very latest we'd only had them in
a few games remember mother this is your
first day out you mustn't get too tired
no I'm saving myself dear I have to
cousin Cora's coming tomorrow is Mary
coming - yes dear - don't touch them
I'll bet you knew it we have any more of
this material yes we do
[Music]
this one is genuine imitation wisdom the
original design by jr. yeah isn't this
the darlingest thing it's exactly what
I've always wanted
how much is this lovely pug dog $15 Man
$15 gee whiz mother we could buy a real
life bloodhound for $5.00 isn't he
perfectly adorable oh I know I shouldn't
mrs. Dane how nice to see you are you
quite recovered almost this is my first
day out we've missed you at the church
you remember mr. Walley how do you do
miss mr. Moore defeats the Sunday dr.
Lloyd was ill oh I can't tell you how
much I enjoyed your sermon even my
husband enjoyed your sermon we just come
from the board meeting of the foreign
missions I'm taking mr. Walley home to
Heinz
I had to drop in here to pick up a
purchase I won't be a minute is your
parish in the city yes it's on the
outskirts my church is inaudible far oh
wait there are you acquainted not urban
park no I don't believe we know it's all
there mr. Morley would this be possible
my husband mr. day if we lower the
collar it'll be a very fine fit you
won't find a better suit of clothes in
the city for $15 oh it's not the price
it's the money thank you for holding it
for me welcome goodbye mrs. day I hope
we meet again soon goodbye it was very
pleasant meeting you again I think it
was divine providence I shall be
delighted to be of service
goodbye goodbye may I work it
oh no it's against the rules
[Music]
Oh what did you bring home more medicine
for dr. Bartlet paid us off didn't he oh
yes
Oh jiminy you scared me I've got to take
$15 right down to my queries I bought a
suit there this morning and I said I'd
have the money this afternoon gee that's
too bad
what's too bad well will you see
Clarence what dr. Bartlet paid us off in
medicine Oh God well he thanked us too
for our services to mankind but my suit
I've got to have it tomorrow and besides
they're making the alterations I've got
to have $15 maybe you could offer them
15 bottles of Medicine oh they wouldn't
take it McCreary's don't sell medicine
father
Vinnie hey I'm home
good afternoon sir how's your mother
Clarence oh the ride this morning get
her a lot of good she'd be well enough
to go to church with us next Sunday
ah fine father have you noticed I
haven't been kneeling down in church
lately don't let your mother catch you
at it then I have to have a new suit of
clothes right away that doesn't make
sense I can't do anything in your
clothes that you wouldn't do well if my
old clothes make you behave yourself I
don't think you want to wear anything
else oh no you're you and I'm me I want
to be myself
I mean suppose I should want to kneel
down in front of a girl why in heaven's
name should you want to do a thing like
that I've got to propose to a girl
sometime Clarence wait but for $15 I can
get a good suit of clothes why don't you
begin you two talk as crazy as room
hello be neat you're feeling better
today thank you you don't have to hurry
home from the office every day like this
uh what business where it is no use
going to the office at all yes you do
look better Vinnie what did you do today
I got the Carey's in took the boys for a
ride and we stopped in a block RiRi and
oh Claire I have the most wonderful news
for you who do you think I met mr.
Morley Arnie never heard of him remember
that nice young minister who substituted
for dr. Lloyd one Sunday oh yes right
young fellow preached a good sensible
sermon Shortland ooh ought to be more
ministers like him
well cleared he is Paris is an Audubon
Park you know way up above Harlem nobody
knows you up there you'll be perfectly
safe safe
what are you talking about I've gone all
over everything with mr. Morley and he's
agreed to baptize you oh he has the
young whippersnapper very nice of him we
can go up there any morning we don't
even have to make an appointment who
said I was going to be baptized at all
why Claire you did now you gave me your
promise your sacred promise you said
I'll be baptized I promise I'll be
baptized well what if I did
Claire I'll write you a man of your word
Vinnie we all thought you were dying so
naturally I said that to cheer you up as
a matter of fact the doctor told me
that's what cured you oh it seems to me
pretty ungrateful of you to press this
matter any further my being well has
nothing to do with it you gave me your
word you gave the Lord your word and
you're going to March yourself up to mr.
Morley's - it's the morning before you
go to the office and be christened if
you think for one minute why in the name
of Heaven is that you will think I'm
going to let you add the sin of breaking
your solemn and sacred promise I demand
to know what that repulsive object is
perfectly plain what it is it's a punk
dog what is it doing in this house I
wanted it and I bought it
you spent good money for that Claire
don't try to change the subject how much
did you pay for that atrocity I didn't
pay anything for it I charged it charged
it I might have known how much was it
$15 $15 for that I saw don't you call it
lovely work of art an eyesore it will
look beautiful sitting on her bed
cushioned by the fireplace in the living
room if that sits in the living room I
won't furthermore I don't even want it
in the same house with me get it out of
here you're not going to get out of this
room until you set a date for your
baptism I'll tell you one thing I'll
never be baptized as long as that
hideous monstrosity is in this house Oh
all right Clarence that pug dog goes
back this afternoon and he's Chris first
thing in the morning you heard him
didn't you Clarence you heard him say
that he'd be baptized as soon as I got
this pun dog out of the house you hurry
right back to McCreary's with it and be
sure they credit us with $15 Oh mother
why we were at McCreary's I happen to
see a suit I'd like very much in the
suit was only $15 well Clarence I'm
afraid your soup will have to wait until
after I get your father Kristin no I
meant that since the suit cost just the
same as the pug dog if I exchange the
pug dog for the suit
y-yes then the suit wouldn't cost your
father anything why how bright of you
Clarence to think of that I better start
right away before McCreary's closes yes
let's see if we're going to take your
father all the way to Audubon Park
Clarence on your way back you stop at
the livery stable and tell them to have
a cab here it'll come tomorrow morning
mother a cab do you think you ought to
we can't walk all the way to wall turban
Park but you know what a cab does to
father it's a very important occasion
all right get one of their best cabs the
kind they use at funerals
those cost $2 an hour and if father gets
mad well if your father starts to argue
in the morning you remember he agreed to
it we both hurt him I hope you know this
Clarence is returning the pug dog yeah
that's a sign you're getting the
faculties back don't dawdle Clarence
[Music]
vini it's good to hear you singing again
[Music]
on the way uptown I stopped in at
Tiffany's and thought you were to go
something what you might like it
I'm glad it to please you oh come here
how sweet of you I don't know how to
thank you
and it's thanks enough for me that's how
I have you up and around again know when
you're ill Vinnie this house is like a
tomb there's no excitement that's the
loveliest ring you ever bought me now
that I have this you needn't buy me any
more rings well if you don't want any
more what I'd really like now is a nice
diamond necklace Vinnie do you know how
much a diamond necklace costs yes I know
Claire but don't you see you're giving
me this shows I mean a little something
to you now a diamond necklace
good heaven if you don't know by this
time how I feel about you so we've been
married for 20 years and I've loved you
every minute of it
what did you say clay I said we've been
married for 20 years and I've loved you
every minute of it but if I have to buy
out jewelry stores to prove it if I
haven't showed it to you in my words and
actions I might as well well what have I
done
nah it's all right Claire I'm just so
happy happy
you said you loved me that beautiful
ring that's something else I didn't
expect oh Claire I love surprises
that's another thing I've never
understood about you Vinnie
now I'd like to know what to expect then
I prepare to meet yes I know Claire but
life would be pretty dull if we always
knew what was coming
well it's certainly not dull around here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
well then Harlem the burning for you
what's your name
Margaret says dr. Margaret we've got one
market announced at home they call me
Maggie sir all right Maggie if a name's
Margaret that's a good sign maybe she'll
stay a while do you know boys your
mother used to be just the same about
cooks as she is about maids never could
keep them some reason well one day about
14 years ago yes it was right after you
were born John my you were a homely baby
[Laughter]
good morning boys mother morning wait a
minute why you look at saw you a dress
for a wedding no idea yeah oh good night
yes Thank You Claire sit down Vinny sit
down boys Thank You Paris where seems to
me everyone's all dressed up this
morning what's on the program for this
fine day
well this afternoon may Louis's mother's
giving a party for everyone in mais
dancing class
Harmons going today I don't want to go
mama
don't you want to go to a party and get
ice cream and cake may loathe ice tries
to kiss me when you've got a little
older you won't object to girls wanting
to kiss you
Willie Clarence this is bu mr. day where
should I put it
oh that's for me I think take it
upstairs Maggie you come in a pack you
bring it here that's it
see it's for me father Clarence day
Junior look that's for McCreary's and
it's mark charge what is it all right
it's nothing for you to worry about what
at least I think I should know what's
being charged to me what is it clear
stop your fussing it's a new suit of
clothes
Clarence and it isn't costing you a
penny it's mark charge $15 it's costing
me $15 and I told Clarence Claire can't
you take my word it isn't costing you a
penny I'd like to have you explain why
it isn't because Clarence took the pug
dog back and got the suit instead of
course and they've charged me $15 for
the chute
nonsense Claire we gave him the pug dog
for the soup don't you see then they've
charged me $15 for the pug dog but
Claire make god we haven't got the pug
dog we sent that back well hmm what well
no wait a minute Vinnie the chute
well there's something wrong with your
reasoning I'm surprised at you when
you're supposed to be so good at figures
it's perfectly clear to me Vinnie
they're going to charge me for one thing
or the other
don't you let them well McCreary's
aren't giving away suits and they aren't
getting away pug dogs why it should be
clear to a child that if Clarence sent a
pug dog back Dave I will not have that
botanical freak in this room John have
you been going around this town selling
medicine Yes Mother
dog medicine no mother not dog medicine
this letter from mrs. Spriggs says you
sold her a bottle of this medicine and
that her little boy gave some of it to
their dog and it killed him now she
wants ten dollars from us for a new dog
yeah let me see that lucky well you
should have given it to a dog it's for
humans
boy it's Bartlett's beneficent balm made
from a secret formula have you been
going around among our friends and
neighbors selling some patent nostril
but it's good medicine father I can
prove that bye mother Vinnie what do you
know about this nothing Claire but I'm
sure John no I mean that day mother
watch enough you're going to every house
where you sold a bottle of that
concoction and buy it all back but it's
a dollar a bottle I don't care how much
it gets here I'll give you the money now
how many bottles did you sell 128 a
hundred and twenty-eight Claire I always
told you John would make a good business
man young man you'll have to come down
to my office with me I have even the
money to buy back that medicine
128 dollars ten dollars more for mrs.
Spriggs dog that's 138 dollars Thank you
very
but it's all coming out of your nose
that means that you'll not get another
penny until the whole 138 dollars is
paid up I'll be 21 years old
Oh God that's another Claire what's
wrong
[Music]
Oh gypsies are back don't know what
answer the door they're moving in on us
again in baggage here you tell them to
get back in that cabin drive right on to
Ohio if we could turn our relatives away
their extravagant enough to take cabs on
horse cars run right by outdoor quiet
and behave yourself John come up with a
bed why do they always have a pulse on
the fur got any warning fine how are you
darling fine thank you
have you been a good boy no Claire the
girls are here well here we are again my
my it's so nice to be back
how do you do mr. day how do you do have
some breakfast we had breakfast at the
depot well we practically finished ours
I haven't finished my breakfast well
then sit down Claire don't have a cup of
coffee
anyway Mary Cora Meggie clear those
places yeah don't let your kippers get
cold maybe some coffee yes where's
Clarence he must be upstairs moving his
thing so you can have his room again oh
oh honey we can't stay overnight grandpa
eva's has been failing very fast and
that's why I have to hurry back we're
leaving on the five o'clock train this
afternoon
well Cora it certainly is good to see
you again well who can that be
well this time it can't be another
special delivery letter for Clarence
while you were in Springfield our
postman was kept pretty busy it's the
cab man dad what cab the cab mister take
us to altar Bell park Oh who's going to
Audubon Park we all are Cora the most
wonderful thing has happened
Claire is going to be baptized this
morning Vinnie what are you saying I'm
saying you're going to be baptized this
morning I am NOT going to be baptized
this morning or any other morning
you promised yesterday that as soon as I
said that pug dog that you'd be baptized
I never said anything remotely like that
Clarence was right there and heard you
that's why I ordered the cam okay
you send that right back I'm going to
see that you go to heaven I can't go to
heaven in a cab well you can start in a
cab I'm not sure they'll ever let you
into heaven but I know they won't unless
you're baptized they can't kick me out
of heaven on a technicality can they
stop quibbling you may as well face it
you've got to make your peace with God
until you stirred him up I had no
trouble with God Whitney come get your
sunday hats Clarence John Yes Mother
hurry we're ready to go oh my prayer
book Harlan come let me fix your tie
penny are you mad was it your plan that
my own children should witness this
indignity why Claire they're big proud
of you
I suppose Harlan is to be my godfather
Vinnie I won't go through with this
thing that's final
if you feel that way about I do so we
won't take the children with us I'm not
talking about the children I'm ready
mother
Oh John Vinnie I haven't time for
anything like that this morning I've got
to take John down to my office with me
and give him the money to buy back that
dog medicine but it wasn't dog medicine
sir young man we're starting downtown
this minute you do no such thing
you gave me your sacred promise that day
I almost died yes and she would have
done if we hadn't given her some of that
medicine that proves it's good medicine
you gave your mother some of that dog
medicine John you didn't yes we did
mother we put some in your tea that
morning
sure do you realize you might have
killed your mother
you did kill mrs. Spriggs dog John I
have to give considerable thought it's
not how you were to be punished for this
no Vinny when I think of that day what
wait we might have lost you you're all
right now thank heaven but what I went
through that afternoon the way I felt
I'll never forget it you forgotten it
already what do you mean what was the
day you gave me your sacred promise yes
but I wouldn't have given you my promise
if I hadn't thought you were dying and
you wouldn't have almost died if John
hadn't given you that dog medicine don't
you see the whole thing is illegal
suppose I had died it wouldn't make any
difference to you you don't care what we
meet in heaven or not you don't care
whether you ever see me in the children
again Oh Vinny you're not being fair to
me it's all right Claire
if you don't love us enough there's
nothing we can do about it
but that has nothing to do with it I
love my family as much as any man all my
life yeah there's that cab what enough
to go all the way to Audubon I want
enough we ride trip would take all
morning and those cabs cost $1 an hour
this is one of their best cabs this cost
$2 an hour well then why aren't you
ready get your hat on Oh
tarnation hallelujah Domon young lady if
I hadn't been for you no one would have
known whether I was baptized or not
[Music]
Oh God
good morning mr. day going to the office
oh I'm gonna be baptized
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you